hello everybody hello hello oh my gosh there was like
there's so many like life updates i wanted to give you guys
today there's so many things going on right i got every day
okay it's like before stream work after stream work it's not
calm down at all yet it's it's like oh my god leak, but I
can't because contracts.
It's just, I'm so excited.
The next couple of months is gonna be like, there's just so
many things packed up the next couple of months.
Let's just say, I can say this, I'll say this.
Let's just say the Doki Bird World Tour.
Let's just say there's a lot of conventions lined up.
so there's like one of these things that's been like on the
like on the back burner like not back burner but there's
been like a lot of things regarding like convention wise
because I feel like I can say stuff like that because it's
not just like you know it's not one convention there's like
multiple conventions that's like in the works and that's
like one of the things that I've like you know I really
really really wanted to like meet you guys I really want to
meet my dragoons and you know like I never had the chance I
mean I did have some chances but you know there was like one
instance where I you know it wasn't by choice it wasn't my
choice like
where like I was able to meet you guys last time um and so
like this is like one of the things
ever got a chance to meet like Canadian goons as well
Canadian dragoons as well as like uh like for like
conventions in Canada I wasn't able to do like any I was I
wasn't fortunate enough to have like an experience to do
like a convention in Canada or like being able to do like
more worldwide conventions and stuff like that um so uh
there's I'll just say like you know the Yoki bird world tour
could be a reality
It's actually crazy Okay, I didn't Okay, same with like for
those who don't know For those who don't know and don't
follow me on Twitter There was like stuff like Guys, Medi,
I'm getting my passport immediate Thank you in the super
chat, thank you Medi, it's not just Canada It's a world tour
It's It's a it's a world tour.
That means I would be in various places in the world I might
even be in America.
You don't need to get a passport So One of the things I've
always wanted was to be able to meet like dragoons around
the world and I was Lately I haven't been fortunate enough
to sort of have you know a little sort of be able to do that
um hi friend thank you for the one uh one ship give this
ship thank you thank you um and uh and i'm trying to like
try not to say too many things to get into i'm trying not to
get in trouble right now chat so i'm trying to like limit
what i can say and what i can't say but like uh some if you
guys weren't following me on twitter uh uh i be power i buy
power and hait sent a PC.
Remember when I kept telling you guys, you guys were like,
Doki, please like buy a new PC, Doki, for the love of God.
You keep crashing.
By the way, I'm still have, uh, by the way, I'm still using
my old PC still.
But anyway, they're like, please.
And I'm like, I, I, I know, guys.
It's just that there is a PC that's sort of stuck in
Canadian customs right now.
And finally, it's finally unstuck.
It's been stuck in Canadian.
I swear It's been stuck in Canadian customs for like about
two weeks now like about like like it's been stuck for like
maybe like two to three weeks in Canadian customs Because I
don't know I don't know why but it's been stuck there for a
very long time But today well technically like yeah today we
sort of like got the PC finally After we sorted it out with
everything but it was actually it was I wouldn't say it's
like actually insane because like I didn't realize this I
thought I was just unmarketable like I legitimately thought
I legitimately thought I was just you know I say my mind too
much or like I'm just unmarketable I'm not cute enough or
like I'm not the cute anime girl that like that fits the
mold or like I thought I was like just unmarketable and like
I was like oh I didn't try hard enough but like it's
actually crazy but there's been so many like sponsors and so
many like conventions that have like reached out to me and
was like we've always wanted to work with you and like and
i'm like really me i thought i thought i was just
unmarketable i did like we've always wanted to work with you
doki and like it's crazy there were so many there are so
many and i was me i was so surprised conventions i was like
wait what really you want to be to be there i'm like and
then like okay because so like they need you need to charge
like we charge when you're doing appearance fees we charge
like um you have to charge yourself for appearance fees you
know you obviously can't do it for free because how the am i
gonna survive like
so like um they're like how much is your appearance fees for
like conventions and i was like oh it's this much is it too
expensive i hope it's enough like i was like i hope it's not
too expensive i was told by my i was told by my manager that
this is like that should be like the general range for
appearance fees and then and then like one of my friends
who's um who's one of my friends who stuff, she was like
telling me, she was scolding me and was like, your PSVs are
too cheap.
And then I was like, I don't know
what I'm doing.
I've never done so.
And then my friend was like, you're too cheap.
What the fuck?
Like, you need to charge more for your PSVs.
They all want you right now.
You need to charge more.
You're way too cheap.
And I'm like, I, I don't know.
I was like I just I just want to I just wanted to go to
conventions and like meet dragons I don't know what my price
is so yeah I'm like every day every day I'm like oh no don't
worry I'm it's US dollars because I was like bro the US
dollar right now is so fucking good at the moment compared
to like any other country i saw this thing it was so sad i
was like so sad because like i don't know you guys saw the
twitter post but i don't remember which japanese twitter was
but there was like a japanese twitter that was like trying
to be like it was that was like oh please please buy our
stuff like on twitter because apparently the yen is so bad
right now that they're trying to get like americans to like
buy stuff in their store because of how bad the yen was
because it's crashing apparently and they're like they're
like please uh please use the us dollar right now it's like
because it's just a lot us dollars like really really good
at the moment and so they're like asking people in the
states to order stuff in japan just because of how bad the
yen is yeah it's actually crazy so that's why like when
they're like do you want to want us to pay the appearance be
in US dollars or Canadian dollars I would like US
I'm just like US dollars please no matter what US dollar
because I have a US bank like one of my bank accounts
accepts US dollars because I have separate US and Canadian
so like I'm like if the Canadian dollar crashes at least
like you know I can just convert my US dollars to Canadian
because even you know even the canadian dollar is pretty
fucking garbage right now so i'm just like yeah i would a u
.s please
no betty thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
kick violently in my sleep i injured my cousin once i get my
own bed now right i scream in my sleep thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um but yeah that's why like
oh, my calendar is getting more and more packed every day
because like I've been getting a lot of like offers to do
like conventions or like events and stuff like that.
And I'm like, yes, yes, yes.
I was like, it was like, oh my God, I did like check my
calendar.
I was like, do I have an event?
I was like, oh my God, does this overlap with this other
event that I'm doing across the world?
Because obviously it's all like virtual.
So I'm like, okay, we're good.
And I'll is the day this is going to be the date before the
other convention so i can do both technically and i'll be
like yes um the reason why i'm taking a lot is because i
never had the opportunity and i don't know if obviously you
know i don't know if the next year i'll be i'll have the
same chances again i'll have the same chance i'll have the
same opportunity to be able to do a lot of these conventions
to have like so many fans from around the world uh
supporting me and so like i don't know next year obviously
you know next year i don't know what i'm gonna my popularity
is gonna be like next year you know i don't know if like you
know people uh if like i'll have the same opportunity um as
i do this year so that's why i'm just trying to like take as
many chance opportunities as i can before you know before
we'll see what next year is gonna be next year doki is gonna
be so uh so that's why i'm trying to take as many chances to
meet as many dragoons around the world as possible um uh and
like just to have these opportunities because you know they
still need to be able to you know sell the tickets and like
be able to you know have enough people for the venue so i'm
like oh my god what if next year i don't have enough
dragoons to fill up this venue oh and then they'll be like
sorry doki we can't get you because you can't fill up this
venue so i'm like okay i gotta do it now i gotta i gotta use
the Because maybe, now I have enough dragoons now.
So, I will always have imposter syndrome.
I know.
I'll never change.
I'll always have imposter syndrome.
So, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Anyway.
Let's see.
broken bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for when the Canadian dollar collapses Shin, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kids, listen to Doki.
Take advantage of other.
No, no, I didn't mean that.
No, Shin.
I do not endorse this super chat.
I do not endorse you're manipulating my words right now.
Hero, thank you for the five gift that shows.
Thank you.
thank you the dude who got doki to come to convention for a
hundred bucks and a roll of lid thank you with a super chat
thank you thank you um uh but yeah it's been a lot of work
behind uh behind the scenes right now and i'm just really
excited when i met world tour let's just say like um i will
have a convention i would be like i wish to be showing up at
a convention at like in one of Not fucking Antarctica of
Almost every continent I will there will be a convention
that I'll be going to for like that'll be like a guest of so
like I'll say that that like I won't get obviously I won't
give names because like you know We're still negotiating and
stuff.
So it's like I told you the world tour the international
world tour
What are things I want oh my god.
Okay, I need to tell you guys the story.
I've been like like holding back the store i've been holding
back the story from the collab because like i realized like
uh i shouldn't like it's like such a weird story to tell but
basically uh recently so recently um i received some
packages so i do have my own personal po box for like
receiving packages that are like you know receiving business
packages and stuff from like events and like sponsors so
like i and like from the auction too so like i have a
personal po box for like the auction items that i received
and uh events and sponsors so a few days ago uh my mom
picked up the items from that po box and like uh gave it to
me and then we were opening up the packages you know so like
there was like items in there from like the auction and like
some sponsors So I was opening up the packages and like I'm
gonna have to use a code word so like it was going okay Like
it was it was going okay.
I received some really cute plushies and stuff like in like
Um artwork but then oh I opened one package and when I
opened it up It was like I'm gonna use a code word because I
don't want to get in trouble So when I opened it up, it was
like a bag of grass and I was freaking out because I've
never seen that before.
I've never seen like I've never like seen it before like
like ever because I you know I
I don't like that was freaking out because I was like what
the fuck What?
I was like, did my address, my PO box get leaked?
I was freaking out.
I was like, oh my god, did my, who sent this?
Did my PO box get leaked?
Like, why is there, why is the bag of grass heat?
I was like, oh my god.
I was fucking freaking out because I was like, wow, I was
like, what is it?
And then, and then we saw the, we looked at the package, and
then apparently someone else used to rent this PO box, but
they didn't change the address.
So, so it got, so it got delivered to me because it's my PO
box now.
But I, I was so scared because I legitimately thought that
someone actually sent me a, I don't know.
that someone leaked my ad my PO box address and then sent it
to me because I don't fucking know and I was like oh my god
and then my mom was like laughing at me because like it was
just so ridiculous it was so fucking ridiculous I was I was
just like holy fuck I was like oh my god am I going to go to
jail
um so so that that happened to me like a couple of days ago
i didn't want to tell the story i didn't want to tell this
story on like the collab because i was like oh no that's
gonna be too awkward that's gonna be so awkward um um but
yeah that i literally i literally thought someone leaked my
address i was freaking out and anyway um but yes anyway for
the i buy power the Hyatt custom PC.
It's been in the works for like a while now regarding like
the custom PC itself.
By the way, this is like a custom, one of a kind PC made
just for me.
And, but, but like I said on the tweet, look forward to
future special announcements that may or may not be related
To, like, a PC.
So, if you're thinking, oh, man.
Should I save my money for, I don't know, something related
to, like, I don't know, PC stuff?
I don't know.
Maybe.
It might be.
Might be a hard...
Maybe.
I don't know.
I'll confirm or deny anything at the moment.
Just maybe.
Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Seen at recent events.
Can you play my so franchise, franchise Gears Award, please?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, what?
What does that even mean?
What is this?
Is this a, was this like a chat GPT super chat?
Is that an actual sentence Scene of recent events Can you
play my sole franchise Gears of War please?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not a good username.
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
Oh!
Gear's of War is getting another game soon.
Oh, that would be sick.
I want to play the original first though.
I really want to play the original events original Gears of
War games before I touch the before a touch the uh the the
newest one um i've always watched my dad i watched my dad
play the first three gears of wars uh as a little as a
little dokey so i really wanted to experience it myself i
heard the new fallout show was really good uh i was like
reading i was planning on watching the new fallout show
because what's his name kojumbo recommend sorry uh
sorry uh jimbo's done it again uh but he like recommended on
he recommended on twitter every time he recommends stuff on
twitter he's i don't know it's usually been like pretty
accurate and like when he doesn't like something when he
doesn't like a show he'll just be like i watch this show but
if he does like it he'll just be like oh my god it was
pretty good i just love like his reviews because it's so
obvious when he doesn't like anything he just be like i
watch it and but then if it's something he enjoyed he'd be
like oh my god it's so good like the actress was pretty
pretty well like the acting was pretty well done versus i
watch this what a what a lad um let's see uh cass thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you kojimbo is father of
pure cinema thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh but yes anyway as i guess i just realized we did like a
fucking 23 minute like catch up zatsu without actually doing
the game uh but for those who don't know this game is called
would you rather and basically it's like will you press the
button it's like all the uh these are like basically like
stream games type deal because they were super popular back
in the day like back with like let's players so like will
you press the button uh would you rather uh what's the other
one ask the genie guy i forgot his name i and then it was a
higher or lower stuff like that anyway i was i realized oh
my god i can finally do would you rather uh and so basically
they gave us two choices uh would you rather and then you
when you pick a choice you get to see who is like the
majority pick like oh which side of people uh want to pick
and stuff like that so you know if you're like the majority
you're like the you're like a sheep or like you know you you
have your own way of thinking you think outside the box and
everything so it's like basically like the walking dead shit
so you know there'll be like your choices oh here are the
people who made the same choice as you stuff like that but
and yet but this one's more like would you rather um anyway
so would you rather scream loudly while for the first 30
minutes after waking up i would honestly choose scream
loudly while you're asleep because i feel like you know how
like there's like those like uh like those like sleep
deprivation tanks what's this like no sensory deprivation
sorry not sleep deprivation sensory um those like sensory
deprivation tanks and then when you go into like those
sensory tanks you like fucking like go insane you can the
longer you spend in there the the more insane you get
because when you have your senses like you turn crazy or
something so i feel like if this happens to me every day i
think i go crazy i i feel like like 30 minutes of just
nothingness by myself i feel like i just go insane in
general and i feel everything i don't want to feel stuff
better i feel like because then like you can't hear or see
right but that doesn't stop your fucking inner demon demons
or your imagination so i feel like your inner demons and
your imagination would go fucking wild because you know for
the first 30 minutes because you're trying to like invent
something in your head especially if you have like a super
active imagination and stuff so i'm just like that doesn't
sound fun and i don't want to like feel something more
intensely too because like you know what you can't what's
that thing where you can't see or like hear your other
senses start improving more and I don't like that my my
other senses don't need to improve anymore I don't want to
feel stuff more I'm okay I'm okay with the current amount of
feeling so so so I rather I just cuz like screaming loudly
while you're asleep.
It just happens when you're asleep.
So, like, it only affects other people.
It affects my neighbor.
That's fine.
Fuck my neighbors.
Like, who cares about what they think?
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Scream loudly while sleeping because I'm not the one
being... Yeah, exactly.
It's not affecting me.
Like, who cares about...
I'm going to need I may be okay someone made a good point it
will affect my throat but like what if like but what if like
you know I I just like tape my mouth shut so be like
silently screaming so um like is less work than ah so in the
end in the end it wouldn't I'll just I'll just drink a lot
of
Okay, maybe I'll sleep.
I'll do like, you know, maybe I'll do like, like what are
those like intense naps?
Like there's like a sleep cycle where you only sleep like
every certain interval.
So if I sleep, if I change my sleep schedule in a way where
I only sleep like particular intervals, like REM sleep,
what's like power naps and stuff like that, the REM cycle,
then I'll be fine.
That'll be fine.
productive some people say it you think it's not healthy but
then but you don't you think it's not healthy but how would
you know that have you ever tried yeah check me don't try
this by the way don't sleep in normal sleep schedule only if
you have scream loudly while you're asleep anyway anyway I
think scream loudly while you're asleep is the way to go oh
well those people don't know what they're talking about
they're fucking sheep nice they're just sheep they don't
they're not cultured enough they're not smart enough that 39
I don't know was it 31 that 31% is like those it's like you
know how they're like you need to be smart up to understand
brick and morning it's like being the one percent chat I was
being the one percent guys because I know what I'm talking
about all right be able to explore the universe or be able
to explore the unknown of the earth.
Okay, I'm not even gonna make a poll.
I was gonna make a poll, but like, I don't even have to
debate.
I'll be the universe.
Because usually, the explore the unknowns of the earth is
just like primitive stuff.
Like, you know, just be like, here's a forest.
Like, here's the forest that's never been explored before.
I don't care.
Like, you know what lives in the forest?
Fucking insects and bugs.
You know what lives in the fucking universe?
Like, We don't know about this in the universe.
There could be aliens.
To be fair, we're going to be the aliens if we're exploring
the universe.
But like, one is obvious the choice.
Like, what kind of question is that?
Like, 39%?
Like, oh my god.
Those guys are stupid.
Now, those guys are definitely stupid.
Be stranded in the jungle or be stranded.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't even need to make a pull out of this either.
Of course, the jungle.
The desert has no water.
The jungle?
I can charge.
a coconut like there's more chances to die in the desert
from dehydration and hunger than there is to the jungle and
also sunburn dude fuck the sun uh but don't fuck the sun uh
exactly the desert has nothing the junk yes the jungle has
wild animals that i can kill and then eat guys the animals
in the jungle are food so easy oh what about the poisonous
frogs what about the poisonous scorpions and snakes snakes
exist in both like what the fuck do you mean there's snakes
in the desert too you can't avoid them they're everywhere
kaz yeah but there's always water in your sand like you said
right it's all one big beach eventually but i don't have a
horse to find the water kaz look So that's why I'm saying
like there's already scorpions and snakes in the desert and
also the jungle At least the jungle has like animals I can
eat and also water I can drink easily Lots of predators.
There's lots of predators in the desert too.
You just don't there's a lot of predators in the desert too
It's just that they wait for you to die and eat you instead
because it's just easier you die by the jungle like you die
by the by the whole ecosystem of the desert first before any
predators fucking comes in to eat you like all right i bet
you i'm the majority here i swear see look you're the 16 and
that's not the special like lower percent like i was in the
beginning that was the that was the you are wrong percentage
all right spend your entire okay this what I'll make a pull.
I'll make a pull for this.
She's right, guys.
Exactly!
Of course I'm right.
Summer at beach versus summer in mountains.
Oh my god, no, fuck the beach.
There's no way I'm gonna choose the beach.
The beach fucking sucks.
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, here's why.
Here's the reason why the beach okay but like what is the
scope of the mountains though like how tall is the mountain
is it like is it so tall that i can't breathe like i need
like an oxygen tank to breathe like or is it like it's like
mount everyone's type type of mountain or is it just a
regular mountain like a hill is a hill a mountain or is hill
like a baby mountain anyway no fuck the beach no matter what
i don't like beaches i hate the i hate the sand i hate sand
and then i the ocean because the ocean is just like nature's
bathroom and like the you know like the sewers eventually
lead to the ocean you guys know that right the sewer the
sewers sewages eventually leads to the ocean and like if you
think about it the ocean is not just filled with just the
natures it's not just a nature's toilet it's everybody's
toilet it's everywhere and that is why i would never pick
the beach that's why like ever since like the realization of
me um ever since like the real oh yeah and microplastics by
the way ever since the realization when i was like younger
that i was like wait fishes poop and pee in the ocean i've
never been to the like i've never like touched the ocean
water since
because like you can't be like oh I'll just like I'll just
close my mouth and not breathe the like not like have the
water in my the water is going to be in your body no matter
what like
the the water is gonna be you're gonna taste the water no
matter what and ever since then I just Don't want to touch
the ocean ever since that part Fletch top thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Sudoku, you rather go hiking?
Remember the last time you went hiking?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, but that doesn't mean I'm gonna be hiking in the
mountains.
What if it's a fucking city on the mountain?
You don't know that.
It never said anything regarding hiking.
There could be literally an apartment built onto this
mountain.
And I just never go outside.
Like, you heard of, like, cabin in the woods.
This could be, like, apartment on the mountain.
Like, it could have been a cool-ass resort.
You don't know that.
Same for the beach.
Yes, but the beach still has the fucking sand and the ocean.
The mountains doesn't have sand.
Um.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The ocean salty because of the baby salt.
Fish me, no!
Oh my god, no!
You know what's in the ocean?
Trash island!
You all remember trash island?
That's in the ocean!
There's not just one trash island!
There's several trash islands!
You know what's not on the mountains?
Trash island!
There, checkmate.
Chin, I feel like any physical activity Dokeywood.
That is not true.
I am a very good hiker.
I just choose not to hike because it's a terrible
experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, so yes, I am going to choose spend the entire summer
in the mountains.
People who choose a beach are not aware about the ocean's
toilet.
Or, sorry, nature's toilet.
Okay, you guys are fucking idiots.
God!
Oh!
I'm so...
I don't feel comfortable answering this question.
Okay.
Sorry, I did not feel comfortable debating this.
okay um all right cowardless bro stop being a coward it's
god it's god ethics everyone has everyone has a code of
ethics that was my line
that was my line okay um okay okay burnt food versus bite
tongue i would honestly say uh i would vote oh my gosh but
how hard would you bite your tongue because it's never you
just got your tongue's gonna get like scarred up and shit
and yeah they both okay like i don't is it true that eating
burnt food gives you cancer because that's what my mom would
always tell me i i don't know if it's like one of those like
what like those like mom stories you know mom lies and stuff
so like i can't tell if it's like mom lies uh but yes like
i've ever because like i always like burned food okay but
like not okay not like oh i'll always eat burnt food but
like i always like the the crunch of burnt food so like you
know like the burnt crust and stuff like not like super
burnt crust but like you know a little bit of burnt stuff
like and then like of the crunch and then my mom will always
be like don't eat burnt food you're gonna get cancer so then
so i don't know but then there's like a lot of like those
mom lies um the mom lies that like they say it because like
a lot of moms would say it because like you know parents
love to do scare tactics for children to not do the things
they want to do so they'll be like don't eat this or you're
gonna get cancer don't eat that or you're gonna get cancer
don't do this or you're gonna get cancer like um it's always
um it's always something related to cancer uh because
another thing the mom lies you know like oh don't put your
phone too near your near your head you're gonna get cancer
from the radiation you know the radiation rays from the
fucking phone
so so like uh yeah the 5g's are gonna get you're gonna cause
cancer in your brain um and stuff you put your phone if you
like if you you like fall asleep with the phone in your bed
so i don't know if that's true also because i'm fucked out
of way because you know i go to you know i fucking play with
my phone when I sleep so
um so I don't know actually but I still do it so well we'll
see how lucky I am uh okay anyway but like how burnt is that
food though um and I feel like biting your tongue is like
not great because like it's not a great experience and And,
uh, and like, you know, biting your tongue is never, and
like, you know, having that fucking, uh, you know, like when
you, that, the tongue starts getting swollen at the part
where it, you bit and stuff, it's not really nice
experience.
Um, and it's every time you eat, it's every day, your
fucking tongue is gonna get so scarred up and, like, beefed
out, because, like, you know, it's gonna be, like, resilient
to more bites.
Exactly.
Someone was like, Kira was like, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
I was like, you'll get an infection.
So at that point, I won't die from cancer.
I'll just die from, like, infections.
I mean, they're both terrible.
I won't die from the burn food that caused cancer.
I'll just die from a fucking infection.
Because eventually, my odds are not with me at that point,
because it's every time I eat.
So, like, an infection will get there somehow.
What if I want to eat, like, Like, I don't know.
What if I want to eat something that's a little raw?
Like, that's gonna fucking suck.
So I'm gonna go with burnt food.
Because I don't know how burnt it is.
Um.
And my mod said it doesn't cause cancer.
Clearly my moderator knows what's up.
So I'm gonna.
I'm gonna go with burnt food.
uh uh largas thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you we survived centuries of lead water pipes and mercury
household products we can survive bacon thank you the super
chat thank you thank you why the fuck who chose what is the
10 those are the people who believe that burnt food will
cause cancer like there's no way why would you choose pain
like why would you choose pain over like burnt food you
don't know how burnt it is like you can't burn everything
what if i just drink soup the entire my rest of my life what
if what if i just you can't burn soup okay maybe you can't
burn soup a little bit but it's a liquid it's like you can't
burn water how do you burn cereal There's no way.
What if it's more?
Marshmallows.
Burned marshmallows is okay.
Like, burnt marshmallows is like, all right.
I can pick and choose my food.
There's one, there has to be a food that, like, bypasses the
burnt laws.
Okay, sing versus dance.
Oh, 100% sing.
Like, you can make more money singing than dancing.
I am so sorry.
I feel like, I feel like, like profit-wise, and like, um,
and just like, in general, singing is just the easiest way.
Like, I can make a million fucking covers in original songs.
Like, albums and stuff.
People will, more people will buy albums and songs than
fucking dance videos and stuff.
Like, a singer can, can, don't have to be a dancer, but a
dancer, if they want to be, like, a famous dancer, They'll
have to also sort of be a singer because like, you know,
there's like lots of dance covers like or be in a dance
group I feel like the only way you can sort of be famous as
a dancer is if you're like in a dance group or you're just a
coach of a famous singer Like because you know singers need
to hire dance coaches So I feel like the only way that you
can like make money as a dancer It's just to be like a dance
coach of some like someone famous or like be on a reality TV
show show for dancers like so you think you can dance do you
remember so you think you can dance that and more with the
celebrities and stuff and then what's her name that mom that
had eight kids uh what was it six kids the six tuplets um
was on that show the original karen oh my god so you think
you can dance does that still exist in any way i remember
there was like an episode of so you think you can dance
where it was just oh my god what was it was it like like a
weeb version of so you think you can dance oh my god i'm
trying to remember there was like there was a viral clip
from so you think you can dance where it was some they like
made a reference to like anime culture like don't remember
which one it was it was like it went viral on twitter for a
little bit yeah yeah and you're like i can't remember what
thing you were referencing though i don't think it was an
american version it was like some other fucking country it
um honestly i think reality tv show is dying though uh there
hasn't been like actual good reality tv in a long ass time
uh because like ethically it's like you know because people
realize people realize now that like watching these things
on reality tv is not and ethically it was never good if you
think of because people were like wait a minute is it there
people are like oh my god is it really bad to like uh watch
these little children do beauty contests and then show the
world how fucked up the uh like how fucked up kids pageants
are but like but like frame it as a good thing because i
used to wash diamonds and tiaras a lot as a um as a younger
dokey i watched like diamond tiaras a lot and i didn't
realize things were wrong like i didn't realize how bad the
show was until i was a little older because that show the oh
yeah sorry toddlers and tiaras toddlers and tiaras um
because for those who've never watched toddlers Basically,
like, a reality TV show following around, like, real people,
by the way.
They're not, like, celebrities or anything.
They're real people, real children, um, who do, like, beauty
pageants, like, kids, doing beauty pageants.
And then they talk about, like, you know, the stuff they
have to do, the sacrifices they have to make.
The parents who feed them a lot of sugar.
Like, those, like, pixie sticks, where it's just sugar.
And then they'll be, like, oh.
Oh, you're tired?
You're like, oh my God, my daughter's tired.
Don't worry.
Here's three sticks of pixie sticks so you can stay awake
for the rest of the patch.
And it's so bad.
And then, um, and then also, you know, like, and then also,
like, you know, if they don't win, the child would be like,
am I ugly?
And then, you know, like, oh my god, wow, the children are
gonna think they're like fucking ugly their entire, like the
rest of their life because they didn't win this pageant and
because it's a beauty pageant.
And it was so, it's so bad.
But I was just like, oh, she did, like, you know, Lil Doki
would just be like, oh she didn't work hard enough to win
there was just someone that was just better and then now i'm
like oh my god this is so fucked up so these little kids are
gonna these little kids grew up to be so fucked up like with
like their own perception of like who they are as a person
and because they didn't because of beauty pageants um i want
to know what happened to these traumatized kids that is so
easy to look look for just look at honey boo boo um oh my
god like i think like because of what happened with the
whole honey boo boo shit because like i know like their
parents got divorced and stuff right after um because like
the dad wasn't like super into the whole beauty pageant
thing and like you know the mom was like this made us famous
what are you talking about uh yeah the kids
after that um and then like honey boo apparently was like
super fucking depressed too during that like she did like an
interview being like oh yeah like oh i got like super
depressed and stuff um and yeah it's actually so fucked up
anyway we realize now that reality tv
was actually pretty messed up it was entertaining but then
it got it was like it was entertaining like in like you know
if you don't look past it but then when you think about what
the fuck is going on we're like whoa you know maybe this is
pretty fucked up maybe maybe the shit was pretty
um um and then what else what else oh yeah and there was
also like uh oh my gosh i think like have you guys ever read
that article when you know the pandemic started and then the
people in big brother had to had to like stop filming and
they had to let them go like they had to stop filming and
then the contestants on big brother was like just found out
everything that was going on regarding the pandemic like at
once so fucked up so everyone's like what the fuck you're
talking about dokey so big brother um big brother is a
reality tv show where they grab a bunch of contestants they
could be like you know internet famous people or
semi-reality stars um and everything or like they'll just be
regular people and then they locked them in a they locked
them in a house in a mansion and then they don't let them
see anything on the internet like no news on tv nothing like
no media like they're just locked like actual quarantine but
before the quarantine existed so it was basically like big
brother had a quarantine but there was no pandemic but then
You know, the pandemic happened.
And then, but the people in Big Brother didn't know what the
fuck was going on.
They did not know.
They didn't know what was going on in the outside world.
They had zero idea what the fuck was happening.
And then they were like, and then obviously they couldn't
continue filming because you know the production people need
to be quarantined you know they're like we can't keep doing
this like the production people are like we can't keep doing
this like you know they have to like maintain the house as
well you know like the like they have to like take out the
trash and everything but the production people are like we
don't say feel safe keep doing this any longer we need to
tell them we we need to tell them that the world is going is
exploding right now
and and then but yeah like they had to let them they had to
like give them a reality check and while it was while the
pandemic started getting really bad i was like bro that must
have been fucking terrible holy shit that was been so like
they're like oh i can't wait for big brother i can't wait
after big brother when like i get to go home family and not
have to worry about the toilet paper shortage and so yeah so
then there and then there's like a clip of there was a clip
of stuff of like giving them the news and stuff about like
being like yeah um while you were being filmed in big
brother some shit was going on in the outside world and then
the contestants were just shocked they were like this is
this of the show like they were just like the contestants
were just like is this um is this part of the show are we
are we really like no that can't be real that can't be real
so they went from one quarantine to another quarantine right
after it's like is this a bit like oh my god it was so
Anyway, I don't know how I got to reality TV talking about
singing and dance.
Oh, yeah, dancing with the stars.
But, yeah, anyway, I would choose singing because I feel
like I could do more with the singing than I can with the
dancing if I had to choose one or the other.
Actual, yes, they're acting, right?
Yeah, acting.
Ooh.
Yeah, I figured.
I figured.
Name a famous dancer.
Name five famous dancers.
on the top of your head I bet you can't I bet you can name
like one or two but I bet you can't name five and they're
like only dancers not like singing dancers it's just dancers
all right pants I thank you for that they get the shins
thank you thank me no you can't say Michael Jackson because
that's a singer and dancer you can't say that it has to be
like dancers like they're they're famous because of dancing
not because of singing you can't say Michael Jackson was
famous in the Jackson 5 and he was like a singer in Jackson
5.
It's not because of like the dancing back then.
But I can name five famous singers on the top of my head.
Always have the best hair.
Always have the best neither.
I don't fucking... Actually best outfit.
No.
Okay.
I'm thinking like design wise I think like okay design wise
I feel like outfit matters more than hair I think because
you can have a generic hair style but if you have a really
good outfit to match a lot it's memorable so I would say
best outfit because I feel like best also it's more comfy
too like the better the outfit the more comfy it is as well
So I'd rather go with...
I'm not even going to do a poll for this because I want to
skip this question.
I will do best outfit.
What did I get for best outfit?
Oh yeah, nice 60%.
I knew I was the majority.
Alright.
Make 350k a year robbing innocent people.
Make 40k a year helping people in...
No.
How innocent are they?
They can't be full on innocent.
Come on.
Okay, 350k versus 40k.
I'd be like, But Doki, what about the content?
This is the content.
Look, look.
It can be sort of like Robin Hood, you know?
I robbed from the rich to give to the poor.
I'm the one that's, you know, the more, sorry, not poor.
Rob from the rich to give to the less fortunate.
I am the less fortunate.
I am Lord Kurosus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The outfit.
You can be bald and a good suit still looks great.
Totally not expecting from experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Exactly.
That's actually what I thought.
Uh, tell me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Aren't you a... Exactly.
I'm a thief.
So of course I'll be robbing people.
Like, what if it's like... Okay.
okay but like i can also like uh i can also like give to
give the money to the forged people in need as well guys it
could also do that it doesn't mean that you know i just take
the month take the 350k and then not do anything after that
i could like you know take 350k and then i'll help the
people i robbed they could be innocent rich people they
might like that money might be nothing for them you know it
could be bill gates i could have me i could have like robbed
bill gates 350 000 he doesn't care 350 000 is nothing to him
i'll just rob a billionaire who didn't who like was There's
some billionaires out there That are definitely not innocent
Zach, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you We
all know Guys, we all know There were a lot of billionaires
out there That might have got that billions of dollars Via
unethical means There's no way you can make a billion
dollars Doing stuff the right way Yeah No, don't say that no
billionaires.
Don't say that other than the fact that Bill Gates sort of
cheated, but like don't
Why did Bill Gates divorce with his fucking wife for after
being married for so fucking long a lot of people forgot the
reason why they divorced was because Bill Gates cheated on
his wife Like I feel like a lot of people forgot about that
Like it would be like oh, but Bill Gates but But Bill Gates,
he's just like a lovable grandpa.
Like, he's just, he's just like a lovable grandpa.
But then, like, uh, but then people forgot the reason why
he, you know, isn't married to his wife anymore.
Who's, who he's been together with for, for decades.
People never forgot about that.
So I was like, I didn't even know he was.
married yeah yeah he was he was married also what's his name
amazon guy also the uh amazon guy as well you know like his
wife basically like supported him uh his wife basically
supported him to start amazon so like jeff bezos i can't
believe forgot his name mr bezos but basically like when
jeff Bezos um was like you know oh I started I started
Amazon off of my garage I quit my job and started this
passion project of the fucking garage thing uh people forgot
that like the part of the story that people don't remember
is that his wife had a high paying job his wife was like had
a high and basically supported him when he was when he was
doing the Amazon thing out of the garage so it's not because
of like the whole you know oh my god he did because like you
know how people are like I'm gonna drop out of school and um
I'm gonna drop out of school uh and like become the next
Facebook creator you know stuff like that they're like oh
Mark Zucker like like Mark Zuckerberg I'm going to be just
like Mark Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos and become a billionaire
because all they did was follow their dreams.
The thing is, a lot of those people, a lot of these people
have, also like, you're not, your university's not Harvard.
There's also that too.
You're not a Harvard dropout.
There's that as well.
Because no matter what, Being Harvard dropout Still fucking
brings you clout Because you made it into Harvard But yeah
But anyway They had a lot of resources They weren't poor
They were They got They It's either their parents were super
fucking rich And they gave them a loan Or like they were
actually supported By They were also like supported By like
spouses and stuff like they'll be like it's okay sweetie you
can go to do your dream project i'm gonna still go to my job
support you anyway what was this tangent jeff bezos divorced
his wife too
that was where my tangent so not oh i don't think any
billionaire in the world is I don't think you need it Yeah,
Mr. Bay There was a whole thing about it There was a whole
thing Because like The wife didn't sign a prenup So she
basically took 50% of Bezo's stuff And Bezo was so fucking
angry He was so mad Because like, you know They didn't sign
a prenup Because when he got married He wasn't rich yet
He, he wasn't rich yet, so, so, like, she actually got 50%
of everything, um, uh, Maggie, thank you for the magenta
soup, but thank you, thank, and he's so very rich, even if
he got, like, 50% of everything, he's so very rich, you
know, like, there's, he's gonna die, and he's still be a
billionaire, there's no way, there's nothing, he can go, he
can, Like, spend, he can spend, like, I don't know, 50% of
what he, 50% of what he makes, and he's still going to be a
billionaire.
His wife took 50% of his fucking, like, his, like, his wife
took 50% of everything he makes.
He's still a fucking billionaire.
It doesn't matter.
Like, he can spend 98%.
Yeah, that guy.
He can spend 98% of his entire net worth and he'll still die
fucking more rich than like 98% of us
that's how that's how like just like the reality of things
uh anyway anyway sorry that was a long ass tangent that is a
long-ass tangent I remember there was a website there's a
there's a website that okay I like how I went through that
entire tangent anyway I will rob innocent people if those
innocent people were billionaires because like they don't
care or millionaires you know what some there's some like
there's some actual innocent millionaires anyway this just
this justifies me robbing the rich because they don't care
they don't they don't care that's nothing to them 350 000 is
nothing to a billionaire and a millionaire it's just like
it's what they make in one day It's literally what they make
it one day So they'll not even realize it's God It says
innocent Look There has to be innocent millionaires in there
I believe there is innocent millionaires in there It's so
wrong Look Look If you think about it My wrong turns into a
right I can literally rob just one innocent millionaire or
billionaire and they won't notice.
I'll just rob one of them and they won't notice at all.
I'll rob a baby.
A billionaire's child.
They have to be innocent by then.
Because, like, you know, it's not their fault if they're,
like, super, like, greedy.
It's not the child's fault if they're super spoiled.
They were just raised to be like that So I'll just rob I'm
pretty sure when the baby is born they instantly become a
millionaire So I'll rob the baby and then the billion the
billionaire will just give them back the money They'll just
be like oh child like what if like the child is holding like
you know a sack of money And it's 350,000 I'll just steal
that sack of money and then would be like, oh sweetie, don't
cry.
Here's another million dollars for you to fucking sleep on.
I don't know.
I don't know what they do.
I don't know what those kids do.
Celeste, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you at point-slope formula because you keep giving us
all the tangents?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, all I'm saying is that it won't be that bad if I,
like, steal from one innocent baby because they won't notice
it's gone they they will not notice it's gone that's all i'm
saying oh those people are those people are fucking stupid
they are not thinking at the level i'm thinking right now uh
what the fuck am i gonna do with math i'm sorry we're not
voting What would you do with math?
You have a phone.
What will help you?
What will help you in math?
You're going to fucking calculate the time it's going to
take from you to drive from one end to another.
You know what's not going to help?
You know what else can help you with that?
Fucking Google Maps.
Learn engineering.
Just don't be an engineer.
If you're If you're already pursuing engineering as a
degree, you don't need to be proficient in math because
you're already proficient in math.
I need math to be cider, man.
Guys, if you're already proficient in math, you're already
trying to be an engineer.
You're already proficient in math because why the fuck would
you go towards being an engineer?
How does that make sense?
What do you mean?
Taxes, just pay someone and fucking figure out your...
Oh, wait.
I just realized, like, not a lot of people have the
opportunity to do that.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
Some people...
I have to have someone to do my taxes because I'm, like, I
can't do math.
And also, like, I can afford...
I'm fortunate enough to be able to be able to afford an
accountant to pass forward an accountant to check through my
taxes for me okay um celeste thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i'm an engineer and an accountant and a
former math teacher and i took that personally thank you for
super chat thank you but it's because you're already good at
math celeste you're already good at math you don't need to
be proficient you already have that skill you chose that
career because you have that There's a reason why I'm not a
math teacher or an accountant or an engineer before I had
the before I had the money to afford an accountant.
Do you know who does my taxes?
Who helps me with my taxes?
My parents because I was so fucking stupid.
I am still very stupid.
I'm so I I don't want to trust me with numbers because I
don't trust myself with numbers.
I'm just that dumb i just need you guys to know when i did
the ib program when i did the international baccalaureate um
you have to like do suggestions and stuff like like you have
to give like what classes are you gonna take so for those
who don't know the international baccalaureate is one of the
hard i don't know if it still is but back when i took the
international baccalaureate it's one of the hardest uh
courses you can take in high school for so like if you pass
the ib program um it's basically like a higher tier than ap
so it's like a higher it's like one of the highest tiers for
like uh school like for schooling and um if you pass it if
you pass the ib program um you basically you can get college
credit for free like you can get like uh you can get like
bonus college credit so you can like graduate like one to
two years early basically so i did IB program and I passed
the IB program and I got like college credit so I could
graduate early um but if you can if you get like really good
scores um it's like almost guarantee Ivy League unless you
fail the interview because we had I remember there was like
a student like she was oh I told the story a long time ago
but there was this girl I know in the IB program and like A
lot of people were like scared of her because she would wear
like a fanning pack She would wear like a fanning pack
around and like she had like like knives in that fanning
pack And like her like she would say like her dream is to be
a yandre
she would be like i want to be a yonder to to us because
like she hang like i hanged out with her and like others she
was like in the group i hanged out with um i didn't want to
piss i didn't like i wanted to be her friend because she was
like super she's like incredibly smart and i didn't want to
piss her off because one of my friends told me that someone
like pissed her off one time became friends with her like uh
one of my my other friends told me was like don't piss her
off because she got suspended was because she pulled a knife
on somebody and so i was like gotcha i'm gonna be good
friends with her
okay anyway Anyway, so, so, but anyway, she got a perfect
score in the IB program.
Like, she got, like, a full marks, basically, in IB, like,
which is, like, really, really fucking good.
Like, it's, like, almost impossible to get, like, it's
almost, like, it's very, very, it's, like, the 1%.
It's basically the 1% to get a perfect score, like, the
perfect 45.
that and her first choice her first choice was harvard and
and she got waitlisted from harvard because of her interview
because usually when you get a perfect score that when you
get a perfect score uh you it's almost guaranteed ivy like
guaranteed first choice pick in any Ivy League school
because it's that difficult to get in but because like she
was very intimidating I'll just say she was like incredibly
intimidating a person no she did not get into Harvard she
got into what is that MIT she got into MIT because she
wanted to be an engineer so like She chose MIT after getting
waitlisted to Harvard.
Anyway.
That was not the story.
My story was that.
My story was that basically when you're supposed to give
your class choices, there's like three levels of math.
It's standard level, higher level, or baby level.
Studies.
Math studies.
Math studies is like...
baby level math and then there's standard level and then
there's and then there's like higher level um the counselor
the academic counselor was like i think dohi should do
studies after after i put standard level i put standard
level but the counselor looked at my list and was like you
should do studies and then and then i told my parents that
they're like oh they want me to do math studies and then my
parents were mad and was like she is not doing math studies
we will get her tutors so she can do standard she will have
math tutors almost every other day so she can do standard
level so then the counselor was like okay the reason why was
because they didn't they were afraid the counselor was
afraid that if i like because the reason why is because this
is the school the school was one of those things where like
obviously the grades really mattered because they always
like post up like oh our school got the average rating the
average like ib score is this so they try to convince a lot
of like they try to convince people who they think are too
dumb to take IB to do the lower ring pro to do the other
program because they don't want them to affect the average
IB score that the school has.
So they'll be like, they'll be like, oh, we don't think you
should take IB.
You should take that one instead.
It will be so much better for you.
So they don't, they don't want them to like affect the
average.
They don't want down.
Like they were trying to tamper the stats and stuff.
So that's why they were like, we think Doki should take
studies.
So, because they were afraid.
They were afraid that my math score was going to lower the
fucking IB score.
They were so scared.
So they were trying to convince my parents and I to take
studies.
Anyway.
Anyway, that is why this entire tangent
why is why I was not born to do math that is that's
basically it this took me like 20 minutes to explain but
that was the story I should not be in charge of anything
math related it got to the point where even the counselor
was like I don't think she should be in this level
anyway would you rather supposed to i think they were they
were they were 100 i was so down to do math studies by the
way but it was all an ego thing for my parents because they
didn't want a child to do math studies because like that's a
little i i guess that's a little embarrassing because
everybody else is like standard level and then like me i
would be in the studies level which is basically being like
she can't do fucking math
um um okay be able to walk on water okay obviously fire we
don't even need a pool you all know my opinion about the
water like why the fuck would i need a bro what the fuck i
would rather just like okay water i'll just have like a
fucking what's it called those little lifesavers i just put
on those little lifesavers or those life jackets why do i
need that i could just touch fire you fire.
So, like, you need to have so much protection.
And, like, and like, what if somebody's drowning?
What can I do?
I can't go in the water and, like, fucking save them.
But if somebody is, like, on fire, if a building is on fire,
and then there's no firefighters around, and I'm walking
around, and then there's buildings on fire, I can go in and
save the person.
I can literally run into that building and save whoever's in
that building and be a hero.
If somebody's drowning, they still drown.
They'll still fucking drown.
What can I do?
Watch them drown at a closer spot?
That's easy.
Fire also.
Okay, we're not talking about the oxygen here.
Maybe they're like, you know, what if they're just like in
the i just like get like do like the movies because movies
are so accurate uh i'll just get like a shirt and then like
cover my my face like this and then i'll be fine the oxygen
the fire won't kill me i can breathe through my shirt just
like the movies why would more people want to what do i mean
jesus what the fuck would more people like just want to be
jesus or something oh my god i wouldn't be scared about like
oil burns because like that's like a mini fire what the what
are these questions um this is just uncomfortable i feel
like for like anybody this is just uncomfortable
no no legit though like that is that is just incredibly
uncomfortable like why the fuck would you want that like
what if you're like what if you're like having dinner with
your parents
bro this would fucking you know what okay i'm actually
curious i'm actually curious i know my answer because like
what is just incredibly uncomfortable in general arouse
versus no
all right
like what is i want to know what is chat's answer to this
one is just no one is not just puberty like because like
there's resting points i would assume that like you've
rested there's like rest points like there's no way this is
always like you would have there's no resting it's just
always what if you're at a funeral whatever you're at a
funeral chat whatever you're at a fucking funeral and then
you're you have to like you know go see the fucking dead
body and then you know people are gonna be like whoa are you
tell everybody at the funeral place like at the funeral be
like sorry i have a condition where i'm always like you know
so people be like oh my god that's auntie blah blah blah how
could you like are you gonna tell everybody that so people
won't be like whoa why the fuck is go what what is going on
like i just won't go what if you're like at a will reading
you have to do it in order to obtain whatever okay that's
not true you can actually you don't need a you don't need to
go to the will reading to like get what you want from the
will but like you cannot you cannot always like I don't
understand why the poll is so close it should not be like
54% no there should be more of you guys who agree with me
like bros thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
happens thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
croak thank you for the super chat thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you for the chat thank you thank you
that guy seems to be talking with a lot of experience there
all right how is your how did it fall down how did the
fucking percentage fall down all right i'm gonna go with two
this is just not it i'm gonna i swear why you can never
fucking go near a pool ever you can never go near
playgrounds ever again or like live anywhere like you can
never like go anywhere that's go anywhere it'll be so bad
for you it'll be so bad it's so bad like
Okay.
Uh.
All right.
Be an elder sibling.
Be a younger sibling.
I feel like younger is the best option because I'm an only
child.
I'm in, I'm an only child and like, uh, and like, I don't
know what it's like to be either of these, but from movies
and TV shows, you know, because they're always accurate.
I feel like the eldest sibling is like the the guinea pig
you know where they test out what works and what doesn't
work and then like you know when they're like oh shit that
doesn't work I won't be doing that to the younger sibling so
like obviously all the if they try to do some stuff that
clearly didn't work and cause trauma for the elder sibling
the younger they learned that younger sibling they'll be
like oh yeah it's like the older sibling would be like the
trial run the test child and then the next one would be like
okay we realized what worked and what didn't work so we're
gonna uh we're gonna like try not to do that and then but
you want to be the youngest because obviously they'll be
like um the second child they'll be like all right that
didn't work they're like the second child is where you test
out the theories to see if it was true so like so you test
out the theories that you tried out on the eldest and then
you try to be like okay the middle child middle child we're
gonna try all these other theories and see what work what is
definitely working or not and then finally the third child
is where they're like we perfected it
Where you perfect the whole racing kids thing and was like
we figured it out for real
So middle child has to be the worst I feel like because then
the eldest obviously you know They were born first and then
the youngest they are like oh, I'm gonna spoil you because
you're the youngest now And so I would say youngest also the
reason why the younger sibling it's because like Like, the
older your siblings are, the more likely they're going to
get married.
So when they get married, they have to give you the
unmarried person.
Red pocket money.
So then if you're the youngest, the eldest has to give you
money.
Because they get married.
Just think of it that way.
True, not the red pocket.
Just think of it that way Because the eldest Will have to
eventually And eventually have to get married And like how
someone's like, girl, I'm white Like this only applies To
certain people I'm sorry Anyway, I feel like being the
youngest sibling Is the best option Let's see Good, thank
you for the Super chat, thank you, thank you As the eldest
of six, oldest kid is the test drive model.
Youngest is pampering and spoiled.
Middle kids are normal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you, super chat.
As an elder sibling, you get to form the rules based on what
works for you.
If you play your cards right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I'm going to be the younger sibling.
I didn't make a poll for this because I thought, oh my God,
it was a 50-50.
People who were on the fence were only child.
that you couldn't think as smart as I did.
Lose your sense of touch.
Lose your sense of sight.
I would lose my... No.
Oh my god.
This is actually... This is difficult.
This is actually difficult.
No touch versus no sight.
I swear this song has been playing on repeat.
I'm going crazy right now.
Like...
I swear.
This song has been playing for like 16 minutes I'm skipping
this I was like I swear I've been listening to this BGM for
16 for like forever oh my god um let's see alright lose your
sense of touch or sight actually really difficult.
I don't know.
I'm thinking, like, what are, like, the benefits for either
or...
Both of these are awful.
Yeah, they're all pretty fucking bad.
That's why I was like, I don't know.
They're all fucking terrible.
They're all pretty fucking bad.
So it's such a difficult choice.
I feel like, okay, no touch means you picking up your body.
That's true.
No one believed this story when I first told it.
But, like, there's like this girl in the UK who doesn't feel
anything.
She doesn't feel anything at all.
She's, like, a kid.
So, like, she doesn't feel anything at all.
And then, like, the thing is, though, you know, she gets
hurts a lot.
She gets hurt a lot, but she doesn't feel anything so she
has she's always like getting hurt and stuff but she doesn't
feel anything because she doesn't feel pain uh oh my god
jonathan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
um but like like but the thing the good side about that is
that she can survive getting hit by a car because okay it
depends on like the speed of the car but but there was a
story with her get injured from getting hit by a car because
she doesn't feel anything so she doesn't tense up because
she has zero fear she has zero fear because she doesn't feel
anything and so so she wouldn't she got hit by a car and
because she didn't tense up or anything and her muscles were
like super relaxed um she didn't break anything she had no
broken bones or anything at best she got like Like her knees
were scraped and stuff Her knees were scraped and everything
So she So it was like It was so fucking crazy And by the way
she got hit by a car In front of her family Like that's so
Imagine being a family That watched that happen She like In
front of like her mom And her siblings She got hit by a car.
And they were like, oh my god.
And then she just got up and like walked up to her mom.
It was like, yay.
I was like, holy fuck, that is trauma right there.
She got up after getting hit by a car.
Walked up to her mom.
It was like, yay.
It was like a fucking video interview about it.
And the mom, you can tell the mom was just...
She's going through some stuff right now from that interview
Potato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No touch means no love life.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I feel like I don't know.
I guess like I don't do I really want to I Don't know like I
guess I don't know I feel like if I can't see I can't play
video games I think like
How would I How would I play video games Though So I don't
know I feel like I rather lose my sense of touch You can
Yeah but like It's not It's harder It's gonna It'll be so
much harder To play video games I think I can live with no
touch As a gamer I need my eyes Guys, think of it this way
I'm already lost enough I'm already lost enough With eyes
How the fuck am I getting Now think What's gonna happen with
no eyes If even with Eyes and a map I get I'm like
directionless True I feel like that's even worse I'm gonna
say sense of touch yeah yeah no one chose that thank god
people who debated for like lose okay fast why why why would
anyone pick this we're skipping bro who is the 15 percent
what the fuck is wrong like what the fuck is the ring thank
you for the akasupa thank you thank you who is the 50 that
that like what the are you okay that's all I could think
like are you okay um marry your crush but you will slowly
become oh my god enemies to lovers the perfect trope because
like that's worse you You know, things you like like about
the person and then you slowly hate them more and more and
more that's terrible I feel like it makes the lovers real
But how slow is slowly how so like 90 years still like on
the diet like on the deathbed and you're like a fuck bro bro
I know we got married for like for like the green card, but
bro you bro I think that's romantic too it's just normal
marriage bro bro okay we're gonna we're gonna go with we're
gonna go with this no pull this is to there's no way yeah
why like you're eventually be stuck outside all year be
stuck okay that's just a pandemic that's that's just a
pandemic we've already inside no pull for this no debate why
why would you want to be with nature how is i don't
understand the reason why we went outside is the reason why
the pandemic lasted that
Like, what the fuck?
Alright.
Um, living forever versus versus 10 more years.
Forever 10.
Ooh, this is like such a...
What's it called?
It's such a philosophical...
Like, I guess like a philosophical-esque question.
Like, there's no right or wrong for this.
Okay.
Honestly, I choose Forever.
Okay, no, no, okay.
Okay, it depends.
It really depends.
Because, like, I think, like, forever, um, I feel like
forever, more so than 10 more years, but forever is, like,
pretty fucking rough.
I need, okay, actually, no.
It depends on how, how this is gonna be.
Will I age along with forever?
Can I say young?
Because, like, What if like, you know, I'm like 350 years
old and I am, you look at me and you're like, yeah, she's
350 years old.
Like, I'm just thinking, I won't be able to walk clearly as
I won't be able to eat for myself or use them.
I have to wear like fucking the elderly diapers and stuff
like that.
like that because you gotta admit when you're that old I
don't think you can control much about your body so I'm just
thinking I'm just thinking I don't want to be like I don't
want to look like I'm 350 so also like I'm scared about like
what the world's gonna be after 350 years later I'm a little
scared so so I just think maybe 10 more years is better
because I'm worried about what are the conditions of forever
um because like what happens when the sun explodes I don't
know you guys know this but like the sun is alive
technically um well not really alive but like it will have
the The sun will eventually die because it's a giant ass
star.
And like stars eventually die.
So like when the sun explodes.
What's going to happen to me?
How am I surviving that?
I can't breathe in.
I can't breathe in space.
Yes.
Eventually the sun will die.
And like what the fuck am I going to do when the sun dies?
Like I'm just going to float in space until I land on
another planet.
Like.
because I live forever.
elsewhere.
I guess by the time the sun explodes, we would have the
technology to move to another planet.
You live.
Hopefully no dimension.
That too, Jonathan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So I'm going to choose 10 more.
There's too many variables.
I can't control, but forever.
I don't know if I'm going to be young forever.
I don't know if I'm going to be young forever, or I'm going
to be the age of which am forever of so so 10 more years i'm
gonna pick 10 more years i feel like yeah i'm in a majority
there okay have to walk on all fours where you have to hop
on one foot what if you just don't go anywhere i feel like
you trip more with this though i feel like i don't want to
make a pull for this i feel like you there's more chances to
trip more but then you you looked so okay you both of these
options you look so fucking stupid like no matter what both
of these options you look so fucking stupid yes but then
your hand's gonna touch like unless you wear hand shoes i
guess like by then i'll invest in hand shoes though so like
you know my hands won't be like touching like the gross
stuff But oh my god Well, you walking what if you drive good
quick question this says walk Sorry, glove Sorry in other
words gloves.
That's what I meant gloves
I could just wear gloves so I won't have to like oh my gosh
this is difficult but if I never that's so difficult because
it's like what if like okay like okay here's what I'm
thinking what if I like go to a buffet I have to walk to a
thing where do and then when I have to walk back to the
buffet area like it doesn't work for me i guess i'll have
someone else to hold my tray because like how the am i gonna
like how am i going to fucking i'll just never be able to go
to buffets anymore hold the plate in your mouth i'll never
be able to do buffets anymore i don't just don't go don't
keep there's a very simple answer to this don't go to the
buffet.
But what if I want to?
I'd like to have the choice of being able to go to the
buffet.
I want to have, it's like, okay, it's like, you know, like,
I would never do this, but I'd like to have the choice to do
it.
Like, like, I would not want to commit murder, But I
would...
If the choice comes...
You know, it's sort of relatable.
It's sort of something you can compare.
Um...
Anyway, I think I'd choose...
I feel like...
Um...
I feel like hopping on one foot causes more accidents.
Over, like, walking all fours, wherever you go.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go with all fours.
Anyway, I'm gonna...
to go with all fours, guys.
Alright.
There's more people with hopping on...
Why?
Guys, who wants to hop on one foot?
Give me your why.
I need you guys to explain your reasons.
Who is like the normies?
Who are the normies here?
Who's the normies?
Why would you want to hop on one foot over like on using all
fours?
All fours is the furry answer.
I need no
okay anyway um when the lottery but lose all your friends i
mean that's basically what actually happens remain broke but
keep your friends okay just don't okay but like people on
the internet won't know that like what you can't make
internet friends as well like where this is go uh so two is
staying normal okay no friends but money versus no money
friends okay money no no friends yeah like can i just make
new friends yeah i'll just make new friends I'm just saying,
like, I mean, winning the, also, I like how dated this is
because winning the lottery doesn't even mean you, like, a
golden ticket anymore because of taxes.
Apparently, a lot of, like, lottery winners don't know,
especially, like, if they're, like, they come from, like,
not a lot of money.
They think winning the lottery immediately automatically
means you have money forever.
And a lot of lottery winners do not know that when you win
the lottery, a lot of that money like it was like a 1
million jackpot a lot of that money is just going to be gone
from taxes so mostly you yeah taxes take like 60% of the
million and then you're left with I don't know like 60% of
that and then after but then they'll be like oh I'm gonna
quit my job and like my entire family is gonna sustain with
uh I'm entire lottery is gonna sustain with just the
winnings and then they end up using all their money after
like five years
and then and then they're broke again and then they're broke
and um and then they go back they have to fucking get a job
again or or another thing that happens is that a lot of
people don't want their names uh don't want their names to
be public uh to be public and winning the lottery because
after winning the lottery you have to a lot of your family
and friends and relatives will try to contact you to be like
oh my god congratulations cannot borrow some of that money
and then apparently apparently a lot of them try to stay
anonymous and stuff because they don't want like they don't
want that to happen to them and at one point like i don't
know i read like An article that one family, like the
parents got divorced and stuff, and they're like, The
lottery ruined our lives!
It ruined our lives!
I wish I would never won the lottery!
I read there was like one guy that won the lottery, and he
came over to pick it up with like, with a mascot, and he
never told his family that he won.
He just like kept it in like some trust or something.
He was like, yeah, I'm not telling anybody.
That's so smart.
So, it's like an emergency fund.
Like, he just kept doing his job.
He just, like, kept working the same job.
Pretending that he never won the lottery.
I think he, like, wore a gorilla mask or some shit.
Yeah, a lot of divorces happen and stuff, too, because of
the lottery.
T-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Apparently, winning the lottery in Canada needs you to do a
math problem to receive the money.
option one is not viable for a toky thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh good thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you canadian lottery winnings aren't oh
my god that's so nice that's so fucking nice think of the
super chat thank you thank you i feel like people don't talk
about the lottery anymore a lot a lot of things people don't
talk a lot anymore i'm surprised people still watch tv that
people still have like cable packages i'm pretty sure like
like the people who still watch TV or like I'm sorry any
dragoons that are still watching TV I am so sorry I don't
mean you guys of course if you're a dragoon that still
watches TV and like television I don't mean you guys I meant
the other people I'm no no no don't feel attacked I don't
mean you I mean the other people that's not you
I Anyway as I was as I was saying I I'm surprised like Like
television networks are still making money off of like cable
packages off of cable in general and I don't I never I
haven't had I haven't watched TV in so fucking long honestly
ever since like the piece like ever since streaming services
was invented.
I've just never watched TV again.
Affiliate, thank you for the 10 gift and ships.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Breezy, but if I win, I can give more money to... Exactly,
Breezy.
I'm your trust system.
I'm your bank.
We were branded.
If you were part of the old bank, do not worry.
We've just rebranded.
It's the Doki Bank now.
same interest rates.
Your accounts are still here, by the way.
The Doki bank account is still here.
Your bank accounts are still safe here.
The Bank of Doki is still very safe.
Very good loans.
Very good interest rates.
So just if you ever win the lottery, just open an account in
the Bank of Doki.
Anyway, I'd rather win the lottery but lose all my friends.
What?
Really?
Why would you want to
Broke but keep all my friends.
They've never been poor before Like Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's my deposit Thank you for the super chat.
Like Like I'm just saying I don't think they understand what
the concept of being broke is.
Yeah
Like I'm just thinking like I don't think They understand,
like, what broke really is.
I think they're just like, oh, that's just me.
Um, all right.
Get piercings everywhere possible.
Tongue, I...
Well, I can, like, remove the piercings, right?
All right.
Let's see.
They say broke while still eating food.
Like, I'm just saying, like, when you're broke, you can't
afford, like...
Like, you can't...
be really strategic on how the fuck like on how to survive
day to day like um okay let's see piercings versus tattoos
piercings tattoos but if your friend is a million thank you
for the super chat jp thank you thank you i mean if you're
already broke and you're saying your friends are really a
But you're still broke like it's the same problem like like
that different like I'm just saying like it's Then you
wouldn't be broke You're like my friend's a millionaire, but
you still have the same problem about being broke You're so
then you still have that problem
Um Um Anyway, I would say, okay, I don't know, okay, okay,
the thing is, but, like, does the head count as the tattoos?
Because if it's just, like, the rest of my body, but not the
head, so then I could just cover it up for, like, if I have
a real job, that's not streaming, and, like, I have to go to
the office, and I have to cover everything up, I guess,
like, is the head, okay, but tattoos on the head, on the
face, Face?
I don't know.
Face tattoos?
In my, this is my personal opinion.
Just not it.
Like, I just...
Face tattoos.
Just, this is my own opinion.
But yeah, face tattoos just not hitting it for me.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I just find face tattoos just...
Yeah.
Like for piercings, I can at least remove the piercings,
right?
Like I can get the piercings.
And then I can just remove it later.
So it's not like...
It's just like places you can pierce.
This is all pretty bad.
I don't think I can get like a normal job.
I didn't either.
Like, like, thinking about it, I'm just like, I can
definitely not get a normal job in either of these
scenarios.
Like, um, oh, and like, my skin can heal, right?
Like, it doesn't mean I have to keep my piercings.
It's like when you get your ears pierced, and then it heals
in the end, right?
So, like, I feel like, you know, I could just get these
piercings once And then the skin will just heal later on If
I don't, like, keep it going That's just cheating It
doesn't, there was no What do you mean?
It's not cheating because it literally doesn't tell me the
terms and conditions I make up the terms and conditions Here
Does she know?
Wait, what do you mean if I know?
You would What the fuck?
tattoo isn't permanent yes they are what do you mean these
are like unless you're talking about like temporary tattoos
like the ones do you know there's like a way you can like
okay i've been all right this is a guilty pleasure youtube
short channel that i've been watching but the the victor
channel there's like a youtube short channel where it is
some guy cosplay pretending as victor from despicable me and
he does these like internet like proving internet videos if
they're real or not and and like there was one he was doing
a short yeah that guy he was doing a short of like of like
those like you there's like a machine where you can print
temporary tattoos on your body and like there was like and
you just like you just like it's like Put the data of what
you want to print.
Yeah, it's a tattoo print, that guy.
Yeah, I was like, that's so fucking cool.
You can literally, like, print tattoos now on your skin,
like, temporary tattoos on your skin.
You don't have to do that whole, like, wetting the paper,
like, getting a temporary tattoo paper, wetting it, and then
put it on your skin, and then, like, hold it on for a while.
There's literally a machine that can just print tattoos on
your skin, print temporary tattoos.
Any temporary tattoo you want, too.
um anyway uh anyway I don't I don't know does that include
the eyes too you know like there's people that tattoo their
eyes people are so fucking weird now like you know like when
technology advances more and more people are like oh my god
but what if I do this now like oh my god technology it is
advancing what if I tattoo my eye Anyway, there was an
article where some lady tattooed her eye and she went blind
because of infection.
Like, why?
You can tattoo your eye to change the color of your eyes.
Just fucking wear contacts.
Like, holy shit.
Just some girl fucking tattooed her eyes so she could change
the color of her eye.
Just wear contacts.
there's color contacts
anyway she went she went blind because uh because she
fucking they got an infection um alright uh breezy I'm gonna
acknowledge your super chat thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you Mario I don't want the piercing in Nope,
thank you for the super chat thingy.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh, I guess I'll go with tattoo.
I feel... Oh my gosh, but pain-wise.
Okay, they're both painful, too.
Because, like, there's, like, parts of your body for tattoos
that's, like, super painful to get.
Oh, they're so terrible.
They're both such terrible.
What do you think is the pick from?
I guess I'll go...
I guess I'll go tattoos.
I'll just never go outside.
I guess I'll get tattoos and I'll also be on Ripley's
Believe In Or Not and the Guinness Book of Records.
I'll just do that.
There's like people who get like, oh my gosh, the body
modification stuff is actually wild.
It's fucking wild now.
Like I remember back then, because back then as a little
dokey, I would collect like Ripley's Believe In Or Not.
and like Guinness Book of Records and stuff like that.
And like there was some fucking wild shit where people would
get like, yeah, Lizard Man.
There was like Lizard Man and like that guy that had like
the whole skull thing.
You know, like the, the, the, the, he tattooed himself so
that he looked like some fucking skull kid or whatever.
And they're like, I'm just like thinking like you can get
some, there's like one person who tried to get plastic
surgery to look like a Ken doll or a Barbie girl.
And like, it's fucking, oh my god, is this the same song?
I swear to god, am I listening?
It's the same one.
Why does it keep going back to this?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not going to do shuffle anymore.
It keeps going back to that one song.
Oh my god, we're going to go crazy here.
All right.
I know like people have been doing some fucking weird ass
body modifications.
All right.
Return every non-essential item you've ever bought.
Never be able to buy anything non-essential again.
Wait.
That just means like I'll...
That's just this but worse.
Wait.
Isn't that just this, but worse?
Like, I have to return everything, right?
Because that means I can buy more.
Oh, then get it back.
Oh, okay.
Then I can just buy it back.
Then that's fine.
Like, non-essential items?
I can't buy toilet...
Wait, is toilet paper considered non-essential?
Right?
Is toilet paper considered non-essential?
Because, like, you don't really need toilet paper.
You can just get, like, a bidet.
That's, that's the, I guess like, uh, you can just use the
shout, like, let's see, essential if no bidet, bidet is
better, um, I remember there was like the South Park episode
where like the toilet paper company is like, NA is like one
of the only places where bidet is not common, but bidet is
actually healthier for your skin.
as well because like the paper the toilet paper like
actually is not good for your skin and stuff like bidet is
actually better but the fucking toilet paper companies i'm
pretty sure the toilet paper company just has a huge
monopoly yeah no it's true if you use like dry toilet paper
it's actually worse for your skin um and like you have to
use like baby wipes or because like you have the paper has
to be wet it's actually really bad for your butt like i'll
just i'll just say that toilet paper is actually pretty bad
for your butt
so so um it's actually better to use like bidets or like
baby wipes but baby wipes is also really bad for I think
like I think like they say like baby wipes is really bad for
um the pipes and stuff uh but yeah like it's actually
healthier to use a bidet um and and I just wish bidets were
popular more popular in NA I just wish bidets were more
popular in NA I miss bidets so much ever since like you know
when you go to Japan and you have a bidet and then you go
back and then you're
I fucking feel like a caveman every time I come back like
yeah do not flush baby wipes it's very bad for your pipes by
the way it's it's very bad um um but yeah I just god I'm
gonna say this one i'm not gonna make a pose for this
because i feel like that's so fucked up if i can't buy
anything non-essential again break into a stranger's home
and stay for two days without them knowing stay why the fuck
would why why would i go outside bro i'm not gonna debate
about this this is terrible they won't know like they won't
know it's like i was never there exactly they leave after
two days after they they won't know I literally break into a
mansion stay at Bill Gates mansion he has so many he
wouldn't care he has so many fucking vacation homes I
literally break into one of Bill Gates vacation homes stay
there for two days and then leave how would they know not
even need a poll I don't need a vote for this all right what
the fuck we want these people just love Drink cold drinks.
Not gonna debate.
I already do this anyway.
Um I already do this anyway.
Like I don't care.
Hot drinks in summer feels so much worse than cold drinks in
winter.
Um, I just choose cold drinks in winter.
I feel like this is fucking terrible.
I could be inside and drink cold drinks.
Tell your best friend all your secrets.
Tell your parents all.
Oh, oh.
Either of them can weaponize it.
Oh, that is difficult.
That is actually difficult.
Parents.
Secret.
Okay, best friend secrets versus parents.
Best friend.
Parents.
Both suck.
They do.
What did he even do?
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
I feel parents.
He has best friend.
Okay.
Wait.
Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, he lives in a bill-gated community.
You'll never get it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I could be Bill Gates like, like long lost cousin five times
removed.
You don't know that.
You don't know that you don't know my genetics.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I feel like parents because I feel like wait if
you if you tell your best friend all your secrets And then
they're no longer your best friend you're fucked You're so
fucked like Because like you can lose friends Much more
easily than parents like I feel like like you can you know I
mean for parents you could be like um what's that word
ex-communicated from your parents but like there's a higher
chance that you're you would lose your best friend over like
being ex like getting kicked out by your parents it's almost
like you're Asian what does that matter even if I get like
disowned from my parents it's less likely um it's less
likely that happened versus getting like losing your best
friend like it's easier to lose friends than to be disowned
like what if i tell like the best friend something so fucked
up that they're like i can't be your best friend anymore and
then they tell people about that fucked up secret like if i
tell my parents okay something super fucked up it was like i
murdered somebody they'll be like how do we You can be like,
but best friends will do that too.
Best friends will, you can say best friends will help you
hide the body.
But will they really, will they, would, it's so easy to say
that.
It's so easy for a friend who's not related to you to say
But will they really do it?
The thing is, they can, they don't have to hide the body
because they'll be like, well, if I just pretend I never
knew you, I won't be involved.
If you kill somebody, they need to help you because her
reputation is connected to you Because they don't want to be
the parents of the daughter who committed murder
They their reputation is on the line Because they'll also be
in the articles too They'll be like oh my god How could this
parent raise a monster who murdered like five people Like so
they have to hide the body for you because they don't want
that to be on the line but then your best friend if you kill
somebody they'll be like holy fuck i'm gonna call the police
because i don't want to be like because they'll have to go
to trial they'll have to go to trial and like they'll have
to go to jail for being involved and they're not even
related to me why would they want to hide the body they're
not related to me they cannot even have to they won't have
to be in trial for anything or like be in every day
everything so i'll tell the parents you guys will tell your
best friend all your secrets like really why would you guys
tell your best friend over your parents i feel like you
might have a secret like if you're like it's like all your
secrets you can't all be clean like don't come like thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you one of my best
for hiding a body they would just eat it thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you I trust a friend do you okay
you can't be fully clean come on I got no secrets that would
send me okay I'm just saying I'm just saying because I don't
want my parents to know what I watch at the night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have no enemies.
I mean, my friend won't judge me as much.
I guess you could say that.
Your friend won't judge, but then what if you're not friends
anymore?
What if you're not friends anymore?
And they know all of that.
My friend, I like how someone's like, don't worry.
My friend has done way worse stuff than me so I'm fine with
that if my parents knew everything I would disappear okay
unimportant thank you super chat thank you thank you I
changed my mind if I have friends they'll probably be as
weird as me my parents said they would my parents said they
would go to the police you don't know that it's all like
figuratively you know deep down your parents do not want to
the parents of a of a son or daughter that murdered somebody
they say that but you know deep down they don't want to be
in the article as a parent that raised a monster they don't
my dad is a cop
um Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you As long as you know what felonies your friends are
committed, you'll always part ways Thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
My parents were in it with pride.
Okay, I guess I was like my parents are very good at
avoiding accountability.
They'll still be in the articles!
Don't be fucking in the articles.
Be like, these are the parents that raised a child who
murdered five people in five different states.
It'll still be in the article.
They will be like, that's the best friend.
No one cares about that's the best friend who was the friend
of the murderer that murdered five people in five different
states.
No one would say that.
Everyone would always mention the parents.
Is this a kid?
No, this is all.
No, guys, it's all figuratively.
It's like, what if I did
people in five different states he he um Michael tried thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you what if I told my
best friend my darkest secret they call me basic thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you anyway I would tell
my parents all my secrets I do that it's all hypothetical
situation this is all hypothetical really I'm the 35 percent
you guys you guys just don't understand me.
All right.
Always have a random taste in your mouth.
Be unable to have taste in your mouth.
Oh, they all suck.
I hate either of these options.
I hate either of these.
They all fucking suck.
I feel like, damn, Dragoons be busy with all these murders.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dark Blade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know if I want my parents to find out how much I
spent on but is that a secret?
How is that deep dark secret dark blade?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Um, one is always oh my god Why are you ashamed
dark blade?
How dare how could you be ashamed dark blade?
Um, I don't know they're all terrible of them.
I feel I'm not making a poll for this one but I feel like I
guess I guess I'll like get used to it.
It could be a random good taste.
Yeah it's gotcha.
You know life is wild.
Life is fucking wild.
It's like gotcha.
Face a zombie apocalypse or face a robot.
Okay this one's interesting.
Zombies versus robots.
Zombies.
Robots.
I'd say like...
I'd say one.
I'd say zombies.
I write fan fiction already have no taste.
Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'd say zombies over robots.
Because robots, you can't use any technology ever again.
Because robots would just like use it.
You know, like robots will like take over all sense of...
It's just Y2K.
Okay.
It's literally what if Y2K happened and the robots just take
over the world.
And, like, I feel like robots having that much power is a
lot worse than zombies.
Because zombies are brainless in the end.
And they're easier to kill.
Robots, you can shoot your gun at a robot.
It doesn't mean they're fucking dead.
You have to, like, fry their circuits or something.
Or, like, SkyNet.
Yeah, it's, like, SkyNet and Y2K.
And, honestly, what if the robots aren't hot?
If evil, why hot?
you for the super chat thank you thank you there can be hot
zombies what happened to that warm bodies remember that
fucking zombie zombie uh romantic movie about like having a
zombie boyfriend like they're they can both be hot
what warm bodies that was a thing warm bodies was a thing
people wanted to fuck the Zombie boyfriend.
I saw it.
It was on Tumblr.
People are so obsessed with the zombie boyfriend thing.
I would say.
Also, Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A true dragon always sacrifices your wallet for the greater
good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would say.
I would definitely say zombie apocalypse.
I feel like.
Okay, a robot apocalypse, eventually, they can...
Okay, the thing is, a robot apocalypse, they can just
rebuild more robots.
That's the thing.
Like, that's endless.
Zombies, they just need to turn other people to zombies.
So, like, by then, you can find a cure for the zombie
apocalypse.
I don't think you can find a cure for a robot apocalypse.
It's more endless, because they can just rebuild themselves.
but they require bodies they require bodies um but like a
robot apocalypse they'll just keep building robots there's
more of a chance to yeah you can say emp but like what if
you there's always a possibility that that like a robot
apocalypse will come back like you can never trust
technology again i don't like that i want to be able to use
the internet while i'm in apocalypse Oh my god Think of the
YouTube content You can get
Day 55 On the search for supplies Like okay I feel like If
we had a zombie apocalypse Now In the current day There's
going to be YouTube tutorials of people like giving like
youtube tutorials on like how to survive zombie apocalypse
assuming that the internet still works you know assuming
that the servers and the internet are still all available
because i'm just thinking like okay i'm just thinking you
know like the youtube headquarters with all the servers with
all the internet servers and stuff for youtube like what are
the zombies gonna do they're not gonna destroy the servers
they're fucking brainless all they want to do is just eat
other other people so like the servers are gonna to be safe
it just needed to be powered up you know like the youtube
servers and like you know we already have the experience
with like the pandemic so we can work at home we don't have
to be at the office to work on the youtube servers so then
we can um how would they destroy electricity they don't have
fucking any neural neuron like neurological like like
craving to destroy the electricity who's maintaining the
power grid i don't know just build a fucking fort around the
power grid i feel like you can be like really rich in
supplies if you're people who can't live about the internet
will give so much supplies to the person who runs the power
grid like
they'll be like here's my they'll be like treated like gods
it's like what's it called what's that called Mad Max.
It's like that guy that owned the water tower.
The person who owns the internet will be treated like a god
just like that guy.
Yeah, internet Joe.
Be like, internet Joe, please.
I need my content.
Here's my food supply for the next two weeks.
If you keep the internet alive, I don't know how to make, I
don't know how to make a, I don't know how to make a desk.
We need desk in our bunker and we don't know.
And we need the YouTube video tutorial on how to make a
desk.
Please, Internet Joe, here.
You shall reach YouTube chrome then shy Okay I stream I die
I stream again Exactly Guys look we need our YouTube
tutorials chat Joe I'm Joe please help us Please give sector
Sector F Fiber We cannot We cannot live with with 10 ups and
10 10 upload speed please help us give us at least 50
uploads and download speed please internet joe
let's see um mr moose thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you zombie apocalypse i guarantee the irs has a
contingency plan for collecting tax is during a zombie
apocalypse i joe please i can never go back to ten joe
parson thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you
all saw the hell divers look the robots were scary the
robots were fucking scary i'm gonna go with zombie
apocalypse all right nice nice all right act on oh this is a
stupid i'm gonna to go with movies and TVs.
This is too much work.
Broadway is way too much work.
Like, this film done.
This is too much.
Also, you're not really famous when you're a Broadway star.
Always be lonely.
This is so sad.
Bro, this is too much.
But this is also so sad.
This is...
Bro, I don't want to answer this.
Oh, as an introvert, this is Way too much as an introvert.
I hate it.
But this is way too little.
I feel, I'm not going to debate about this.
I'm going to say surrounded by others.
Because then I can always have collabs.
Toki.
Stop thinking about the content.
But then, like, I can always have, like, collabs if I want.
Like, it'll be easier to get collabs.
All right.
Okay.
I'm going to do, like, two more questions.
Chat, I'm going to do two more than we'll call it here.
The streamer mindset.
All right.
Video game versus movie.
Video game.
Movie.
I say video game.
Okay, it depends if I'm the main character.
Because I can have respawn.
I can respawn.
In the favorite, I feel like video game.
It depends on what video game it is.
So, it depends on what video game.
But I feel like if I was in my favorite video game, I can
always respawn.
Oh, wait.
My favorite is, like, Professor Layden.
So, like, I'm fine.
I can be Luke!
Luke, my boy.
Professor?
Yeah, I'm going to do.
My favorite movie?
I don't even know what my favorite movie is.
Professor!
All right, I'll say video game.
I don't even know.
I don't think I have a favorite movie.
I don't think so.
So I'll go ahead and go with a video game.
This is not really a debate.
What?
I guess normies.
Fucking normies.
All right, I'm refreshing.
This question sucks.
This is not gonna be my last question.
I'm refreshing this.
This is a bad would you rather.
All right.
I'm gonna try and get a good one.
Uh...
Let's see.
Oh my god, this was terrible.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm going to...
That's not going to be my...
We're ending it with this.
This is like debate club.
We're going to end it with this one.
Oh my god, we're gonna end it with this one.
Alright, alright.
Okay, this is so easy for me, but no matter what choice we
make, we're all horrible people.
Because like...
Because like, a lot of people are like cancer, but then
someone's like, bro, world hunger kills more people.
But like, but, okay, but cancer, but if we cure cancer, my
mom can't be like, this food can cause cancer anymore.
She can't, like, my parents can't lie and be like, don't do
this, it'll cause cancer.
Don't do that, it'll cause cancer.
If I cure cancer, that won't be an excuse anymore.
I like how someone's like, I rather save kids than adults.
too well they're already suffering through many things at
least we'll get rid of one okay if we solve you can't say
cancer patients are already are starving too because they'll
die from one or the other like we say cure world hunger but
they're still gonna fucking suffer from cancer like what
kind of fucking question is that what kind of fucking answer
is that eventually we will You don't cure world hunger.
You just...
You don't cure world hunger.
It's just that...
It's just that we don't provide...
We don't have...
Like, we don't provide food to, like, end up...
Like, we are not good at providing food to people,
apparently.
Because there's already a cure to world hunger, and it's
just food.
It's literally just food.
There's no cure.
the cure we're just not applying the cure um charles thank
you the super chat thank you thank you cancer is harder real
hunger is more of a district yeah exactly it's a
distribution issue we have the cure and it's just food but
we don't provide the food we don't provide we don't
distribute the food we don't know what the cure is for
cancer yet i'm so right we're always being like we are in
the cure for cancer but we still haven't fucking cured
cancer yet um world hunger god equals lesser crime equals
lesser death but cancer is terrible okay anyway meanwhile us
wasting cuts okay i feel like some of that part is so fucked
up but like there's literally nothing we can do about it the
wasting food part because it's like it's like there's a lot
of like supermarkets and a lot of bakeries and a lot of like
um a lot of like uh like food making places where if there's
like an excess amount of excess amount of food they don't
donate the food they just throw it out because it's a legal
issue because what if somebody gets sick off of the food you
donated um they have the legal means to sue you and like in
america everybody loves to sue people like everyone loves to
pursue lawsuits so people don't they're like we have to
throw it away because they don't want to be liable to they
don't want to be liable to be to they don't want to be
liable for it too i know that's like one of the reasons i
don't know what the other reasons were as to why they don't
um um but i don't i don't remember why there was like
another reason why they don't donate the food but it's like
this is like one of the main reasons because they don't want
to be liable for a lawsuit if somebody gets sick off of the
food you donated
if you give it to a food bank then you wave all liability
that's a myth oh my god i believe that for so long.
It's like the whole McDonald's thing all over again.
They can write off the losses.
Oh, it's all about taxes, man.
It's always... Why does this always come back to taxes?
Why does this always come back?
Why does this always come back to taxes, man?
It's just like the McDonald's coffee thing all over again
where they fucking tell you that was true and then you find
all this did you guys know super size me apparently we were
lied to about the movie super size me because apparently the
guy who made that movie who made super size me embellished
it so much that like apparently like a lot of the movies
from Super Size Me is a fucking lie.
I watched that movie in class at least four times.
It was terrible.
I fucking watched Super Size Me at least three to four times
because our teachers were always like, let's watch something
educational.
Super Size Me regarding like the health and the fast food
industry.
What Super Size Me is about some dude that fucking binged
himself with McDonald's and got like incredibly unhealthy.
His wife divorced him after I shouldn't laugh about this But
like it's because I don't know if it's his wife or his
Girlfriend but like his Girlfriend's vegan so
It's either Like his girlfriend or his wife But like his
girlfriend Or wife like left Him because like she's vegan
And then he could never stop eating And he was also, like,
vegetarian slash vegan.
I don't remember which one.
He was apparently, like, vegan slash vegetarian.
And he did the whole Super Size Me stuff.
And then, like, he couldn't go back.
He couldn't stop eating meat.
Like, he couldn't stop.
And then, also, like, he was complaining about...
like the health issues but also he was a full-on vegan and
you cannot go straight into fast food after being vegan for
so long like your body is not fucking your body cannot
handle that if you used to be vegan and you suddenly decided
to just eat fast food like when like there's like shit like
Anyway, Super Size Me was apparently a fucking lie.
I couldn't believe it when I found out.
It, like, broke my world.
It actually, like, ruined reality for me.
Because I was, like, I saw that movie so many times at
school.
And then people were like, by the way, Super Size Me was so
embellished.
Like...
all right anyway anyway a super size though i think the
super size though like for those who didn't know mcdonald's
used to used to like um have a size called super size and it
was like fucking crazy i still i do think the super size
size amount is insane uh so like i would give them that like
i would fucking give them that regarding super size like And
an American portion is so funny I was watching a short about
like fast food portions And it was like it was like like
here are American fast food portions versus like Asia fast
food portions And I'm like Jesus fucking Christ Like I think
it was like a Japan large was like an American like medium
or something And I was like Jesus fucking Christ
I'm just like, bro, what the fuck, bro?
Like the soda cups are just crazy insane.
Anyway, I'd cure cancer.
I'd cure.
It's a rough decision.
I think this is like a good place to end it.
The cure cancer versus world hunger.
fucking hardest hardest talk we had to have i like how i
like how ended it with that
oh my god it was we did it we cured cancer dragoons we
figured it out anyway guys okay anyway um as um i had a
great time just hanging out with all of you it was i had a
fun time debating and hanging out with all of you guys today
it was very fun it was really enjoyable um i knew we could
do it no matter what we can be both terrible and good people
as well because we cured one thing um anyway that was wild
we had a wild time today chat um but i honestly i always
enjoy streaming for you guys and i always enjoyed like
having these with both of you.
with all two of you dragons.
One will debate about the other and then one will debate
about that.
With both two of you dragons it was so fun.
One of them is you!
That's you!
That's right, I'm talking about you.
That's right, you.
She's talking about me!
Yes!
You!
We're both two dragons.
Anyway, I'm going to call it here, everybody.
I hope you guys had fun hanging out with me today.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.